floodwaters have cut off the coastal
city of Wilmington from the rest of
North Carolina Wilmington rainfall total
for the year is higher than it's been
for more than a century of officials are
planning to fly in supplies of food and
water the roads in and out are blocked
no matter where you try to go David beg
no is in cast Castle Haines just outside
Wilmington because he can't get in David
good morning hey John good morning we
are standing on interstate 40 Wilmington
is in front of me and behind me is the
rest of the world we are essentially cut
off look here's the deal Wilmington has
gotten up to 2 feet of rain because of
Florence creeks and rivers have swollen
and roadways have been washed away
within the last 24 hours we went to the
community of Bishop and near the Stoney
Creek neighborhood we saw rescuers with
FEMA evacuating families and pets from a
subdivision where homes have water
nearly up to the rooftops from there we
noticed a lot of people trying to drive
through flood water including a man
named William he was actually hauling
and disaster relief equipment he drove
in yesterday morning in the flood water
and was there for more than 8 hours when
we found him he said listen I don't have
cell phone service will you call my wife
and let her know I'm ok we did but we
also called 911 know his location here's
what we just found out this morning
right now the city of Wilmington first
thinking they would have to fly in
supplies has found out they can drive
them in so here's what they're gonna do
they're going to today figure out a way
to drive in enough food to feed 60,000
people for four days right now they are
planning where they can drop them off
because initially the places they had
are cut off by flood water so again they
have 18-wheelers high level trucks that
they're gonna drive in today we don't
know what time it's gonna happen but
enough food for 60,000 people is on the
way back to you mind about how dire the
situation is David thank you so much